what does social media and technology do
to our dopamine levels have you looked
at this
yeah so social media is essentially has
druggified human connection
we are
evolved over millions of years to want
to connect with other people we are
tribal creatures we're social animals
my colleague rob malenka recently showed
that oxytocin the love hormone when it's
released binds to dopamine
neurons in the reward pathway and causes
a release of dopamine it's not really a
surprise to most of us we are motivated
to connect and our our brain gets us to
do that by releasing dopamine so it
feels good to connect that means that
all of those meta experiences that tell
us we're making a connection also
release dopamine so we we have a
dopamine release when people like us we
have a dopamine release when people
agree with us we have a dopamine release
when people um you know enhance our
reputation
we have a dopamine release when we're
experiencing the same emotion at the
same time as other people so that's very
powerful which is why social media can
really be like this frenzy because when
we are getting outraged at the same time
as somebody else that releases dopamine
when we're laughing at the same time as
somebody else that releases dopamine
when we watch somebody watching a video
and we have the same reaction as they
have to that video that releases
dopamine which explains the mystery of
why we would ever want to watch people
watching other people but it makes
perfect intuitive sense reaction videos
explained exactly yeah right
but what social media has unfortunately
the potential to do is actually drug-ify
human connection
by contributing to all of the features
that make something addictive and that
is access quantity potency and novelty
so if we have easy access to our drug of
choice which we do
with social media
then we're more likely to get addicted
especially when you compare that to
prior to social media what you had to do
to go out and meet people right first of
all you had to get off the couch you had
to go out and find the people
most of them are going to be average
looking and average interesting right
it's not like that now you know you can
just stay on your couch and swipe right
or swipe left swipe left quantity right
so if you think about almost all
traditional drugs and alcohol i mean
typically eventually you run out you got
to go out and get more tick-tock never
runs out
if you look at potency
how do we make things more potency we
combine we potent we combine two drugs
together and that's exactly what social
media has done it's combined beautiful
images with sex with gaming
with gambling
with music with flashing lights to make
it all the more potent
and then finally novelty dopamine is
very
sensitive to anything that's new
especially if it's something that we
liked before but it's a slight variation
on that and these ai algorithms are
basically
learning us figuring out what we like
before and then suggesting something
that's similar but slightly different
which automatically triggers dopamine
automatically triggers our search and
explore function our treasure hunting
function you know when we're off and
running looking for that next slightly
better thing and then finally
social media has enumerated things it's
given it numbers and for reasons we
don't fully understand when we enumerate
things or when we have rankings or
number of likes that's really
reinforcing we tend to like that why is
it that some people find certain things
rewarding uh in terms of how we
interpret them so for instance one
person might really get geed up by
gaining followers on instagram but
another one might be really interested
in shooting people in a video game and
another one might be funny cat videos is
this more of that genetic spread from
the group do you think or is there
something else going on
i think it's mostly um just natural drug
of choice you know that some people are
just going to enjoy certain drugs and
not others and that there's variation in
the human population but some of it too
has to do with our social networks
so addiction really does spread like a
virus and we're more likely to try and
use drugs that people in our social
network are trying and using so if you
hang up
hang out with a bunch of video gamers
you're more likely to get online
partially because it's you know socially
enhancing it and binds you to them which
is you know also important for people
are behavioral interventions the only
solution then that dopamine detox and
you spend time away from your drug or
your activity of choice is it just down
to behavioral interventions or is the
pharmacological solution for this can we
can we pray the addiction away what's
going on
yeah so addiction really is the
quintessential biopsychosocial disease
which means that we need biological
interventions psychological
interventions and social interventions
behavioral interventions
kind
like a dopamine fast sort of cross all
of those because biologically what we're
doing is allowing reward pathways to
reset themselves allowing ourselves to
look back and see true cause and effect
but also in order to accomplish that we
often have to change our environment or
change the people that we hang out with
so it's also psychological and social
but the that's not the only intervention
we can also use
chemicals to help people stop using so
for example naltrexone is an opioid
receptor blocker which can be used to
treat people not just with opioid
addiction but also with alcohol
addiction alcohol is mediated in part
through our endogenous opioid system so
by blocking our opioid receptors we make
the alcohol less reinforcing which means
people can use it not just to help them
stop drinking altogether but actually to
reduce the amount that they're drinking
and that's a really nifty tool because a
lot of people don't want to stop all
together they want to use in moderation
and when they use naltrexone what they
say is that i i'm just better able to
stop at two or three drinks rather than
progressing to six or seven drinks i
also just want to jump in and emphasize
that addiction really is a spectrum
disorder mild moderate and severe and
this dopamine fast intervention is only
really going to work for folks who are
sort of on the borderline between being
addicted and being a little addicted or
maybe a mild to moderate addiction in
terms of
just asking people to do it on their own
for people who are more severely
addicted the dopamine fast is equally
important but they probably won't be
able to do it entirely on their own they
may have to go into a rehab a
residential treatment center or they may
have to be given you know um medications
like an opioid receptor blocker in order
to even make it possible for them to
abstain so i i just really want to
emphasize that we're talking about a
spectrum disorder and my book is mainly
targeting people who are a little bit
addicted um although the the ideas in
there apply really to addiction more
broadly as well what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace